also new at noon an arrest has been made  in a reckless driving incident that  killed two people over the weekend  court records show 22-year-old rodrigo  cruz now faces charges including open  murder  the incident happened yesterday on  hollywood boulevard near sahara in the  east part of the valley  metro police say a group of cars were  racing when a passenger in one of those  cars  allegedly leaned out of the window and  hit a woman riding a bicycle  she fell and she died even though she  was wearing a helmet  the person who pushed her down then fell  out of the van as well and also  died cruz the driver is due in court  later this afternoon